bereit zur jährige elektriker kevin
steht stark unter druck
vor einer woche haben wir uns zusammen
damals make-up routine angeschaut
in diesem video hat sich damit für ein
date fertig gemacht heute sich so auf
ihr geht und das kann ich auch richtig
nach meine damen und herren auf diese
reagieren wir heute zusammen beiden
gehen gemeinsam zu dem vereinbarten
treffpunkt mit shrek muss die 23 jährige
feststellen dass es sich bei der
ausgewählten location um ein oma
kaffeehandel brand
was ist denn bitte ein oma kaffee auch
sie hast du dir aussuchen gesten und ich
kommen fünf minuten einfach nach [ __ ]
taktik alter als wenn es die dame nicht
mal ein hinkriegt den typen zu treffen
wieso als moralische unterstützung
moralische unterstützung ist es dein
ernst marianne dies auch keine fünf mehr
so einfach hat diese moralische
unterstützung da nur noch anstatt dass
sie sich dann zumindest weiter weg setzt
nie direkt an tisch daneben verschwand
und ziemlich aufgeregt betritt
nein nein es war ja so klar ich wusste
es dass die redaktion da sonnen
schlanken typ mit brille hin setzt rtl
ihr seid wagen sind bevor die doppel
sich da nun zu ihrem date bewegt eine
ganz kurze sache wieder die wir
natürlich auch in der letzten aktion
gemacht haben und zwar habt ihr mir
wieder zahlreiche bingo sätze in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde in der
heutigen doppel reaction sind folgende
kandidaten dabei
beleidigungen von marianne die wir nicht
kennen nur text an ihren stoff die wird
bestimmt heimlich was fressen wie sieht
es denn hier aus dass du dich nicht
stimmt also diese 7 kommentare sind
heute dabei und wir warten nun mal ab
wer der erste gewinner sein wird nicht
gegen den namen kevin aber es war ja so
klar dass rtl alter
der macho vom foto entpuppt sich in
natura als schüchtern und das ist nicht
wahr
das kann ich wahr sein
[Musik]
das gibt mir hier
wieder den rest ist schon was bestellt
dann bestimmt der suchende walliser
drauf aber ich habe beim reingehen
wissen was sie war auch ein tag wie
important dans malta ernährung wieder
vollkommen und wo einst erzähler und mal
was das was machst du so haben wir schon
einiges besprochen aber erzähl doch mal
ein zwei jahren tochter
wir wissen durchaus spüren das hört sich
gut an
ja ich bin elektriker ich hätte
vorhersagen können kevin gross schlank
brille elektriker so das komplette
gegenteil von heute einfach und das
macht mir auch spaß also mache ich gerne
war schon sehr aufgeregt steht stark
unter strom
sonne ist genau mein typ die würde ich
auch mal gerne unter strom setzen
okay es war mein und diesem jahr auch
sympathisch wenn irgendwas gemacht haben
muss sagen der elektrik kann ich dir
auch gerne helfen sie den herd und
backofen anschließen
es habe schon gerne kochen ja haben wie
man hört dass angeschlossen danke größte
kortmann wahrscheinlichen dem elektriker
geben kann das ding ist jetzt gerade
weil er da wo der herren noch kein
einziger bingo hat die härteren
vorgekommen naja die meisten gesetze so
deutlich gesagt von marianne was macht
die marianne eigentlich meine mama hat
mir das hier empfohlen
[Musik]
und dann nimmst wir uns auf ihre
teilnahme
die wunder noch mal gemacht quasi alles
von mir gesprochen taucht die 49-jährige
ganz unauffällig im karree august kann
man mit krawatte und so ganz gezielt
dann so richtig
damit teilt aus alter das kennt man
wirklich so von marianna also ich bin
wirklich gespannt ob sich die maria
jetzt immer noch ein bisschen
einschalten wird
naja auf obst stehe ich nun mal jahren
also
damit du rasiert häuser echt krass kevin
hat nur ein thema seine mutter
mittlerweile ist dominique nur noch
genervt
ariane bewegt sich zum tisch es ist
heute wirklich das komplette gegenteil
von allen anderen doppel reactions also
alle bingo kommentare die ich
aufgeschrieben habe diese nahezu alle
gegen damme
so wie siehst du denn da austrickst
nicht richtig menschen aber jetzt kommt
die marianne derart und ist total
höflich nein
sie sind ja richtig heißer aus wo kaufen
sie denn ihre kleidung ein wahnsinn mit
und die hat das gar nicht gezeigt das
war so miserabel
wir haben uns ja auch viel zu erzählen
ist ganz ganz gut aus ja du gefällst mir
das ist ja echt grinch und fremdscham
auf einem komplett anderen planeten ich
hätte nie gedacht dass wir jemals auf
einen dollar video reagieren wo sie die
person ist die austeilt und die andere
leute abfuhr erteilt den cetera
wir haben noch keinen einzigen bingo
gewinner also das ist ja enorm und man
so präsident die die stromleitung vom
kraftwerk wir sind in die stadt also die
typische sachen über die man sich
unterhält das ist ja wirklich sehr
spannend meine eisenbahn zu hause sie
läuft mit mit gleichstrom und eine
eisenbahn reisen modelleisenbahn haben
der mich zuhause dies besteht steht bei
uns im keller ist sehr schön
sorina aber da fehlt nur noch dass
die doppel gleich in seinem world of
warcraft gilde einlädt der kevin thum
erwin bisschen leid
doch ich glaube gibt nix mit uns ich
habe mir das ganz anders vorgestellt als
das passt einfach okay jetzt geht's los
ok also jetzt scheint das date an
scheint ein ende zu nehmen habe ich
zusammen gezogen und jetzt hat er ab
oder was nach dominiks deutlichen worten
steht habe ihn einfach auf und verlässt
enttäuscht das café
also das ist wirklich das beschützte day
dass ich das ich je gesehen habe also
wir tun alle alle beteiligten tut mir
leid weil er zweigleisig fahren
[Musik]
die wache ist mal ganz kurz wer noch
eine minute um einen bingo gewinner zu
finden das heißt ich hoffe wirklich dass
die marianne jetzt noch mal irgendwas
sagt us-dollar natürlich daraus gelernt
hat ist dass die männer auch interessant
stimmt
das aber das einzige was du daraus
gelernt haben ja richtig
wir haben
keinen einzigen gewinner die dieser
bingo folge anders hätte mich das
heutige video jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
meine reaktion hierauf besteht anlass
gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
da und schreibt mir bitte jetzt schon
mal für die nächste doppel reaction
einerseits euren bingo satz und in die
kommentare was ihr denkt was in der
nächsten session eventuell dran kommen
könnte und schreibt mir bitte auch unten
in die kommentare auf welche folge mit
dem ich als nächstes reagieren soll
es gibt ja noch immer im gefängnis doch
mal im knast das ist genau das gleiche
luca ich habe gesehen es gibt auch noch
dumme im schwimmbad dom in der pizzeria
also es gibt ganz ganz viele sachen
schreibt mir gern was uns in den
kommentaren unter anderem auch ihr euren
bingo satz und wenn ihr fortnight spielt
er nutzt gern local support wakeboard
weil ja
[Musik]